- The NFC North is as cold as ever.
The Packers are the front,
and in the back we’re forced to eat tough losses.
We’re so hungry to win the division.
- Kirk, you don’t always have to give speeches. We know our situation.
- Justin was DELIRIOUS from hung—
- Hello! Rodgers heard there was some talk
about you peasants making a late playoff push.
- ATTACK!
- Just use up my good years. This is fun.
- We have to free this guy. They say he’s one of the greats.
- Oh, don’t bother. I’m stuck here.
- Oh, OK, next car.
- What do we say to visitors?
- [Together:] We know we missed Mahomes, so please leave us alone.
- We’re the scrappy team now!
- Didn’t you hear? I’ve stopped calling plays.
SET OFFENSIVE COORDINATOR BILL LAZOR TO STUN.
- PEW PEW.
- Aight, I'm gonna chance it in free agency. WEEE!!!
- I wonder if this is as bad as the NFC East train?
- [Announcer:] This train is out of service.
- GODDAMN SUBWAY.
- GODDAMN METRO.
- GODDAMN SEPTA.
- OH GOD, I’M RIDING PUBLIC TRANSIT!
[Techno music]
- ♪♪♪ MARY HAD A LITTLE LAMBEAU. ♪♪♪
- It’s the natural order. Packers on top, Vikings down bel—
- Sorry, we had to stop for the bigger, scarier AFC North train.
- THE STANDARD. IS. THE STANDARD.
- So I says to him, you coach my way, or I let you kick my ass.
- Stand clear of the closing doors please.
- Closing doors better stand clear of me, ya hear?
- Remember, if you see something, say something.
- JOE JUDGE AIN'T NO SNITCH.